SNT - between Star Wars Marvel
planeteers are you the king of keeping
secrets I have developed that scheme yes
I can't imagine so you are brilliant a
Caesar and you've had to portray him at
so many stages of his life and so many
weaknesses and emotions how do you get
yourself in the mindset of the different
ages of Caesar
it started off for me finding that the
chimpanzee I based him on a real
chimpanzee but actually as the movies
went on as the story progresses as the
arc of his journey changes he became
closer to me and so I in this film I
suppose I portrayed very much a closer
my emotions and and working with Matt
Reeves the director on this it was like
we want to take the audience very
viscerally on Caesar Jonas see the world
through Caesars eyes so so I could only
do that in this portion of the journey
by bringing him very much close to my
chest and playing playing his situation
as if it were mine what would I be
feeling if I were going through these
these emotions he circles this is this
loss
I can almost tell watching it that it's
coming from you because you have to let
go of this character that's true I mean
it's it's a really quite strange
situation where like for instance my
kids and what didn't tell the ending of
two would so cross with me so angry with
me because they felt you know they've
grown up they broke the my family's
grown up with the this this trilogy and
what like my kids have and didn't expect
Caesar to ever end I have such a lot of
affection for the character and I think
it is because I played them all the way
through his life that it that I find it
particularly hard to let go this right I
mean that reads a said he wants to do
more movies but I it's hard to imagine
it without a Caesar but given that it is
motion capture I mean is that something
that you would even be open to doing as
another character it's certainly look
that's the great thing about before
capture technology is that it allows you
to to play anything so so it conceivably
you could come back as you know I could
come back as another character and I
love this world
I love the metaphor of using apes as an
amazing analogy for for the human
condition of being able to see ourselves
through through through the eyes of Apes
so and and if it were to be a Matt
Reeves film absolutely this film has
reunited or reignited a conversation
that happens every time you have a movie
come out Andy Serkis deserves an Oscar
do you I mean is that at this point does
is that important to you is that
something that you are striving for or
is it like I tell you what I'm striving
for yes and and something that
frustrates me is that there is a there
has been in the past it's slightly
changing now but there is a prejudice
against performance capture as being as
being something that is different to
acting and it's not it's the the process
that you are playing a role using
performance capture technology he's no
different to going on set as an actor
playing in any live-action character
you're using exactly the same skills you
working with the director on set you're
working with other actors you're looking
into their eyes you're playing the scene
you've done all the build-up of the
character psychologically emotionally
physically all the rest of it as you
would in any character so for me as long
as that's understood Awards aside if
that's the most important thing is that
we don't have to have this discussion
for another and we've been doing this
for 17 years you know and a tire having
to have the same discussion it's almost
starting from scratch people say what's
it like to put on up and fall to get to
see you know you know what's it like you
know is it different to you know how do
you do the monkey movements it's like
it's not about that you're creating a
character and playing a role I do want
my jungle book update you've teased it
as darker savage I mean what are we
getting it is it is it's much closer
tonally to to Rudyard Kipling's original
book which if anybody's read that book
it it you know there is it's a very
Mowgli centric story it's a journey
young a young character that is neither
in the world of you know he can't exist
in and purely in the world of animals
not that he exists purely in the world
of man and it's about him finding his
own identity and it's it's really for a
slightly older audience than the disney
version which by the way I loved and
thought was amazing
and and I thought Jon Favreau did an
extraordinary job that our film is very
different it's it's a live-action movie
it's shot on location it's using
performance capture it's as a sake
totally dark there's no singing it's no
barrier there's no bear necessities at
all
[Music]
you